nadège bonsoir donc une atmosphère
tendue 1 ce soir absolument olivier
halley a forces de l'ordre ont fait
usage de canons à eau pour tenter de
disperser la foule une fouille qui vous
l'entendez peut-être derrière moi est
toujours aussi en colère et qui
continuent de scander des slogans
hostiles aux forces de l'ordre hostiles
au gouvernement d' emmanuel macron elle
est aussi le également envers gérald
darmanin le ministre de l'intérieur et
des forces de l'ordre qui ont fait usage
je disais donc à plusieurs reprises de
un canon à eau on a des manifestants qui
sont mouillés mais qui est tenté bien de
poursuivre cette manifestation qui
veulent faire entendre surtout à leur
mécontentement donc voilà une
manifestation qui s'est plutôt bien
déroulée en début de journée puis qui a
dégénéré au moment où les organisateurs
ont appelé à la dispersion des forces de
l'ordre qui a par le canon à eau sont
restées timides jusque là et qui vous le
voyez peut-être commencent à avancer en
direction des manifestants pourrait bien
peut-être procédé à des interpellations
individuelle a demandé à chacun de bien
quitter lé lieu alors que vous le voyez
aussi un des manifestants qui recule un
petit peu pas tous on a encore quand
même plusieurs d'entre eux qui font face
toujours aux forces de l'ordre donc on a
vu aussi également tout à l'heure un
journaliste qui a été blessé au visage
par un projectile qui avaient été
lancées à destination des forces de
l'ordre peut-être un petit mot avec
faouzi mais louche
faouzi lellouche qui est un gilet jeunes
qui participaient à cette manifestation
aujourd'hui donc quéquette qui se passe
les cannois otis rapproche un peu plus
des manifestants qu'est ce qui s'est
passé pourquoi est-ce qu'elle a dégénéré
cette manifestation parce qu'il ya un
gouvernement derrière qui veut pas
entendre les gens ils demandent le
retrait de cette loi c'est encore une
loi liberticide comme toutes les autres
qu'il a pu y avoir avant et les gens ils
sont pas dupes ils s'aperçoivent que les
lois qui sont votées
elles sont pas du tout fait pour eux et
ils en ont marre et ils sont excédés
donc comme le gouvernement ne veut pas
entendre attention à vous le
gouvernement ne veut pas entendre et ben
du coup voilà voilà sacré la colère
et puis au lieu de s'en prendre au
gouvernement ils s'en prennent aux
forces de l'homme parce que les forces
de l'ordre c'est le bras armé du
gouvernement
tout simplement avec toutes les la
répression qu'il a pu y avoir des
blessés qu'il a pu y avoir effectivement
les gens ils sont à bout on pousse les
gens à bout et après on s'étonne qu'il
arrive ce genre de choses
merci à faouzi un problème pour vos
témoignages et on va vous montrer un
petit peu les changements le changement
de tactique idée un forces et de leurs
proches elles sont restées pâti pendant
à peu près les hennuyères et puis passer
à l'action
régis maintenant le cannois été avancé
puisque au bonheur
beaucoup beaucoup membres des forces de
l'ordre bien qu'ils sont inquiets
tentent d'avancer qu'ils tentent
d'avancer à la désormais il se replier
et puis elle devrait passer à l'action
c'est ça mon sous peu la préfecture de
police de paris qui a communiqué sur les
réseaux sociaux qui a prévenu que la
manifestation et bt est bel et bien elle
termine et qui a donc demandé aux
manifestants de quitter les lieux
donc voilà d'une situation qui est est
pour l'instant toujours sous tension une
manifestation aujourd'hui pour dire non
à la loi sécurité globale et son son
article 24 alors que vous le voyez aussi
on attend de nombreux manifestants et
bien à pieds les genoux à terre qui l'on
demande aux manifestants justement ça va
c'est boulot c'est donnant donnant
reculer le cannois
ont de nouveau été déclenchée par un
palier sans celle de l'autre
on a toujours ces manifestants tués bien
malgré l effet est une voix qu'ils aient
été ciblés par ce cannois au tir est
toujours et bien mobilisés qui peut
passe et continue de faire face à ces
personnes ou si elle continue de faire
face aux effets de la barre je suis un
peu désolé je suis tombé sous les balles
à genoux vous vous restez avec nous
sinon je le disais extrêmement tendue
avec des oui non mais vous restez à
noter également qu'ils continuent d'être
relancé
vous intervenez dès que la situation
évolue n'hésitez pas reprenez votre
souffle
on vous retrouve un dans quelques
instants en direct avec nous